how's it going everybody it's Warren and
tomorrow is the official launch day of
Disney Plus and with it comes a whole
slew of a ton of different Marvel
content now we obviously have a ton of
new Marvel TV shows that are going to be
coming exclusively to Disney Plus
however they're still going to be a ton
of old Marvel movies that exist in the
MCU TV shows and animated shows as well
so let's go over all of the Marvel
content that is going to be available
tomorrow at the launch of Disney Plus so
Disney Plus and Marvel Studios have
officially announced every single film
that is going to be available from the
very start of Disney Plus which is going
to be tomorrow November 12th so we have
from Marvel Studios on Disney plus
Captain America the First Avenger
Iron Man ant-man Iron Man 2 Captain
America the Winter Soldier Doctor
Strange Thor guardians of the galaxy
Avengers age of Ultron Captain America
Civil War Thor the dark world
The Avengers guardians of the galaxy vol
2 Iron Man 3 Captain Marvel and of
course Avengers endgame so these are the
movies that are going to be available
right from the launch of Disney Plus
with obviously more movies going to be
added later on down the road there's
also going to be a ton of different
animated shows including Spider Woman
x-men the animated series this is what I
grew up watching and this is what really
made me a true Marvel fan from the very
beginning so if you haven't seen x-men
the animated series I highly suggest you
watch it and then we have other classics
like the Fantastic Four the Silver
Surfer x-men evolution then we have the
Iron Man animated series spider-man
spider-man and his amazing friends and a
ton of other animated shorts both new
and ones that marvelous put out over
time
Marvel is also producing new exclusive
content for Disney Plus such as Marvel's
hero project this is going to be
following 20 kids who are doing amazing
things in life who are true superheroes
then there's going to be a
behind-the-scenes of Marvel show you can
watch and of course we cannot forget all
of the new phase 4 and phase 5 Disney
plushies that are going to be
exclusively on Disney Plus of course we
have the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
series 1 division Loki Marvel's what-if
series Hawkeye and recently announced
Miss Marvel moon night and she Hulk all
of
are going to connect to the MCU and
Kevin Feige himself has said that these
characters will appear in future MCU
films so as you can see there is a ton
of Marvel content coming to Disney Plus
not to mention the mandalorian which is
said to be the greatest live-action Star
Wars project ever directed by executive
producer for Marvel and director for the
Iron Man films Jon Favreau and I'll be
covering that content on here as well so
if you have any questions about Disney
Plus like whether or not it's available
in your country or not go to Disney Plus
comm or if you'd like to ask me any
questions you can follow me on Twitter
and I'd be happy to answer any for you
let me know which show or movie you are
most excited about coming to Disney Plus
and don't forget to subscribe and like
the video so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof